the former rookie of the year one of the
best players in the game damien lillard
joining us from the bubble
morning damian how's life in the bubble
good morning man life in the bubble is
it's pretty smooth
i'm not mad at it at all i like it okay
your thoughts
before you went in the bubble to now
that you're in the bubble
how different are those thoughts i mean
before i went
before i came um my concern was more
like you know i'm gonna
miss my family you know what is it going
to be like
before we got here it was other teams
here and we saw like people was
complaining about the food
um so i was just like you know what is
it going to be like is it going to be
you know a bad situation are we able to
to really pull this off and then when i
got here i was like
i mean this is this is more than
comfortable like
they provide meals it's like a schedule
that we own
everything is flowing smooth um
you know i think the the downtime is
like it reminds me of college
you know how we go to practice we come
back
and it's almost like we just go to the
dorms and you know you kind of see
people roaming around getting food
stuff like that i mean it's it's it's
pretty cool to me man i think it's
giving us
giving us all some some level of peace
you know just being able to step away
for a little bit
i don't think your dorm room looked like
that though it did not
it was similar hey at weber state we had
some pretty nice dorms we had a
four bedroom two bathroom you know four
people told them a kitchen a living room
and stuff like that even though it's not
that big
we have pretty nice dorms what would
surprise me in your uh
your room there
[Music]
i don't think nothing would really
surprise you other than i got a studio
set up
okay so you brought a recording studio
i mean i wouldn't say a recording studio
it's like
i brought each thing that i needed to
record my music so i only got a mic
um i got a software on my laptop i got
an interface
um a microphone like the box to
power up the microphone and that's
pretty much all i needed
have you thought about doing a live rap
performance
from your room we're seeing musicians
who were you know they're at home
and they have a concert would you be
willing to do that
i don't know i kind of like the
the idea of being able to record when i
want to kind of do it when i feel like
it
instead of being like all right you
signed up for a concert let's go
i'm saying like i don't want that
obligation i just i like
i like it being there so i can do it
when i feel like doing it
can you turn is the is the so-called
studio
within uh distance there of turning and
showing it's not i'm actually i'm
actually out
like in the front part of the room oh
okay and what's the bracelet that you're
wearing
this one yeah this one is like
our um before you leave your room every
day you got to have this
it's um it's the kids to your room
actually whenever you
go eat or purchase anything this is how
you pay for it
um so i mean it's is pretty much
what's the one thing you have to have um
to get in and out of each
door in the hotel you got to scan it and
it has to turn green
before you can even proceed i guess so
um it's the one thing that you know is a
part of everything so
are you allowed to socialize yeah
like you can go to teammates rooms
um i mean i wouldn't i don't think they
would suggest us just hanging out
in the rooms but i've been to cj's room
like he ordered some food
it was delivered up there i went up
there grabbed the food but i mean we
haven't just been
in each other's room i think you'll see
that more downstairs like in the
restaurant you'll just see people kind
of down there eating talking
the players lounge people playing ping
pong and stuff like that eating together
watching tv
so um i think that's as as close as it
gets
we're talking to damien lillard the
blazers five-time all-star
who's the mvp in your opinion
i don't think you can go wrong with um
lebron or giannis but in my opinion i
think
miss lebron how come
um just because he's the number one the
number one seed in the western
conference
um and i feel like he's had a dominant
season to be
and what is it for him you're 17. um
leading the league and assists um like i
said before number one in the west the
level that they have been playing at
um right before the season was suspended
um
you know i don't think i don't think
it should be any argument with you know
either guy getting an award but um
i would say lebron because of how he's
been able to
um take that team from a non-playoff
team over the last
however many years and now they just
jump to number one you know that's
that's his impact obviously you got a.d
there too but um
you know i think lebron is definitely
worthy of being an
mvp how different is lebron now to when
you first came in the league when you
faced him
um i think when i first came in the
league he was just
he still it's weird because he's still
like super fast and athletic
but when i came in the league it was
like it was unbelievable
and i think that's the biggest
difference you know he's obviously he's
older now
um he's always been a thinker you know
a smart player um a heady player and now
i think that's even
that's even heightened um but he's
he's less speed and athleticism and
um and power i guess and more of a
cerebral
pick his spots manipulate the game
control the game
and use his athleticism and you know his
gifts and spurts
a lot of people jumping on the blazers
bandwagon here damien
that you guys yeah i want i want him to
stay off
[Laughter]
why you want to be sneaky you want to be
quiet stealth
no i want to just i want to just let it
happen
you know i mean i want to go out there
and let the let our play decided i don't
want people to start saying oh the
blazers can beat the lakers and the
blazers busy you know we gotta
we got a lot of work to do to even put
ourselves in that position so
um you know we don't want people
giving people bulletin board material
and all that type of stuff
they don't really make me no difference
but you know how much rather float under
the radar and just you know show up and
do what we got to do
do you have a basketball in your room i
don't
jimmy butler is dribbling the ball i
guess somebody was complaining about him
dribbling the ball
at early in the morning and i get i
heard that but i mean
i don't i don't really i don't really
hear nothing so
our floor is pretty quiet um
but i mean i don't i don't i see a lot
of people out and about when i'm when i
leave my room so
you know pretty early teams got meetings
they got breakfast set up for us
so it's it's hard for me to see somebody
complaining about
somebody dribbling the ball how are the
games gonna feel
you have any idea
i really don't know you know i visited
the one of the
the i guess arenas that we're gonna be
playing in
and um it was a nice setup you know you
can tell they put a lot of effort into
you know building it out and you know
trying to make it as
as normal as possible but um
it's definitely gonna be a different
feeling well i think it's gonna look
good on tv i just don't know how it's
gonna feel if it's gonna be like
that's what i'm more that's what i'm
more thinking about how it's gonna feel
because i was actually on the court
and it felt smaller um
the our bench was like seats weren't
right next to each other they were like
kind of like spaced out
you know i heard we're gonna have to
wear a mask on the bench and stuff like
that so
no man um it's gonna be uh
it's gonna be different it's gonna be
different
i heard you got timeout chairs that when
there's a timeout
they're gonna roll chairs out and then
you sit down
and then they take the chairs and then
they clean them for the next time out
did you hear that
i didn't hear that i heard i did know
i do know that we gonna have assigned
seats so whatever seat you sit in
to start the game that's gonna be your
seat the entire game
and it's also i saw like chairs like
near the baseline
yeah and it was like four chairs it was
like if you want to have a conversation
with one of your teammates or
one of the coaches you got to leave the
bench and walk down there and sit in
those chairs and talk
and then they clean them when you leave
and then whoever else needs to talk they
got to keep going down there and i was
just like man
that's why when people say you know when
they say oh they'll be an asterisk by
this whoever wins and i went
i said it'll be tougher to win a title
it feels like
in the bubble than it would during a
normal season
no i agree i agree because
i think it's a lot of things that
um guys are used to you know used to
having
um that makes them comfortable that
makes them go you know like family for
example
or friends or you know being able to go
having the freedom to go out to eat with
your people and you know whatever it
might be
being in the comfort of their own bed at
home um
stuff like that and it won't be there um
and now you're kind of isolated all you
have is basketball
you know it's it's just i don't know i
feel like
it's gonna be different you know it's
forcing your mind to stay here
um there's no fans there's no home court
advantage
so i i mean it's gonna be tough man it's
gonna be
it's gonna be tough it's almost like a
you know your commitment
you're committing to to just step away
from your life
and come here and focus on this for
months you know what i mean like that's
that's a tough thing to do what are you
uh going to go with on the back of your
jersey
you decided how many more
now did they give you a number uh
like is there a a set number or list
that you could pick from
um i saw it was like a list of um
things that we could choose from and um
i looked over them and i saw a lot of
things that i you know that i would have
been proud to wear on my jersey but i
chose how many more
well uh i'll tell people to stay off our
bandwagon here
um so just tell them to relax man back
up back up oh i know i know i'm gonna
downplay it
we're gonna do this i'm gonna play it
cool and uh nobody's gonna know about
this but uh
good luck down there and uh always great
to talk to you thank you damian
thanks appreciate you having me man all
right that's damian lillard of my
blazers
shh don't tell anybody